[Música]
y ahora vamos a nuestra sección de
economía con nuestro periodista
especializado jorge hurtado jorge
bienvenido de nuevo acá y cuéntenos la
reserva federal de eeuu aumentó la tasa
de interés el banco central
estadounidense endureció su lucha contra
la inflación y aumentó de 75 puntos
básicos las tasas de interés a dore el
rango objetivo de la tasa de fondo
federal se sitúa entre el 15 y el 175
puntos pero no serán los últimos para
clara se esperan otros 175 puntos
básicos adicionales para este año la fed
espera ubicar los tipos de interés en
3,4 por ciento los rendimientos de los
bonos cayeron tras la publicación de
estas proyecciones de la fed que
mostraban una cierta desaceleración del
crecimiento económico mientras las
acciones en wall street terminaron al
alza ahora el temor de los mercados es
el riesgo de que se produzca una
estanflación lo que significa que el
endurecimiento de la política monetaria
podría frenar la economía y no logre
doblegar la inflación escuchamos qué
opinan si los analistas al respecto
creo que fue una decisión audaz de la
fed no estoy segura de que fuera
totalmente necesaria pero creo que envió
un mensaje muy fuerte al mercado de
bonos y a los inversores en su conjunto
y creo que eso es en parte lo que llevó
a la fed a ser ligeramente más agresiva
ahora en lugar de esperar creo que
sintieron que dar un paso más audaz
ahora les permitiría subir los tipos de
interés potencialmente menos en el
futuro
jorge y explíquenos una de las dudas que
tendrán los estadounidenses y es como
estaba afectando esto los bolsillos de
los ciudadanos para claridad que aunque
la intención es bajar los precios puede
convertirse en un problema de cierta
forma a corto plazo por ejemplo para el
sector inmobiliario que es bastante
sensible a la subida de los tipos de
interés los tipos hipotecarios han
aumentado del año pasado y el tipo medio
de contrato de hipoteca fijo a 30 años
alcanzó el 5,65 por ciento la semana
pasada es el nivel más alto desde
finales de 2008 según la asociación de
banqueros hipotecarios el precio de las
viviendas en eeuu ha subido un 38% desde
la llegada de la pandemia esto porque la
escasez de y también por el costo de los
préstamos eran super bajos los datos de
las hipotecas muestran que el tipo medio
de interés fijo a 30 años posiblemente
llegue al 6,5 por ciento en las próximas
semanas otra de las interrogantes es si
la subida de los tipos hará bajar los
precios de la gasolina y los alimentos
la respuesta es no esto porque los
precios de los alimentos y energía están
altos debido a la guerra entre rusia y
ucrania dos productores importantes del
email mol de alimentos lo mismo ocurre
con el petróleo los precios han subido
luego de la invasión por el temor de una
escasez y se agravaron con las acciones
internacionales también los tipos de
interés en las tarjetas de crédito y los
préstamos para automóviles suelen subir
cuando lo hace el tipo de interés
oficial de la reserva federal respecto
al empleo que es otro de los objetivos
de la fed el emisor cree que todavía
puede evitar un gran aumento de los
despidos en las empresas siguiendo la
lógica de que la tasa de desempleo es
actualmente del 3,6 por ciento baja en
comparación con los estándares
históricos hay casi dos vacantes de
empleo por cada trabajador por lo que
las empresas podrían y las ofertas de
empleados sin recortar los puestos de
trabajo reales bueno usted mencionó la
guerra en ucrania y cómo está afectando
esto en eeuu pero también tiene impactos
en europa y es que la semilla estatal
rusa gazprom anunció un nuevo recorte en
el suministro para el viejo continente
el ministro de economía de alemania dijo
que esta medida busca sembrar
incertidumbre y hacer subir los precios
del combustible se trata del segundo
recorte el bombeo y dejaría al gasoducto
nord stream 1 con el 40 por ciento de su
capacidad
el argumento de moscú es que hay
retrasos en la obtención de los equipos
de siemens energy que están en
mantenimiento en canadá lo que según el
regulador energético alemán no explica
el corte los precios del gas al por
mayor en gran en el reino unido y
holanda subieron luego de este anuncio
de gazprom y es un ejemplo claro de cómo
el mercado energético se ha convertido
en el centro de la guerra económica
entre moscú y occidente
juniper que es el mayor exportador de
gas ruso en alemania dijo que sus
suministros desde rusia estaban un 25
por ciento por debajo de los volúmenes
nominados jorge y cuáles son los
indicadores del día empezamos a engels
es un avance después de la del anuncio
de la reserva federal sobre los tipos de
interés en ese país en europa las bolsas
rompieron su racha de seis días de
pérdidas después de que el banco central
europeo anunciara también medidas para
atemperar la caída del mercado de los
bonos y en américa latina
el merval de argentina se vio
beneficiado por este contexto
internacional y la cifra del día es 1700
millones de dólares eso perdió en valor
de mercado hype que es la agencia del
grupo surcoreano beat y es ay se hundió
hasta el 28 por ciento este miércoles en
seúl tocando su nivel más bajo desde su
debut en octubre del 2020 todo luego de
que la banda del momento anunciara que
se tomaría un tiempo para proyectos en
solitario jorge gracias por toda la
información económica y nosotros
continuamos aquí en directo américa con
todas las noticias
internacionales y de todas las acciones
como los deportes y la economía del
mundo
[Música]